there have been a lot of big headlines
lately so here's one smaller bit of news
you might have missed New York City
lifted its coronavirus vaccine mandate
for professional athletes and performers
last week which will allow Brooklyn Nets
star Kyrie Irving to play in home games
more importantly the new rules allow us
to feature an unvaccinated performer
that we haven't been able to have on the
show until now so without further Ado
please welcome for the very first time
our unvaccinated mascot roughy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
that's right ruffy he's already pumping
up the crowd roughy dude it's great to
have you back
yeah and that's my dog he is so much fun
see Grumpy I've been meaning to ask you
ruffy how come you didn't get the
vaccine
[Music]
oh oh raffy you are so silly but
seriously though why didn't you just get
it
oh are you saying you were doing your
own research
they'll have that go
did you end up catching covid
the roof ruffy did you catch covet or
not
oh ruffy was it bad
oh how bad
is is that a noise meter
are you doing a noise meter with your
arm to tell us the severity of your
covet case
did you have to go to the hospital
bud
well why not
oh you were afraid
oh it wasn't bad at all ruffy just a
quick shot in the arm and that's it
you still think that it's the kiss of
death
I don't know ruffy I think you're kind
of a conspiracy theorist if you're not
vaccinated I just hope you're at least
wearing a mask under there
you're not well then stop taking selfies
with the audience members you're gonna
make them sick
oh Rafi I'm sorry did I hurt your
feelings
sorry bud I'm just trying to keep
everybody safe you understand right
[Applause]
it's gotten into you
oh you you think the vaccine has altered
my DNA
and you think a chip has been implanted
in my brain
no no rapping don't you try to raise the
roof your way out of this you get out of
here
Scott Ruby everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]